ein ehemaliger wachturm in berlin heute
ein ort für die kunst die einstige
sperrzone im grenzgebiet daneben liegt
heute ein alternatives stadtquartieren
dort wo die mauer die menschen trennte
befinden sich heute etliche
kulturstätten
hallo ich bin wie ein genie ross ich
werde ihnen hier orten zeigen an denen
nach dem mauerfall etwas neues
entstanden ist los geht's im früheren
ostteil der stadt ist jetzt das
künstlerdorf holzmarkt 25 ansässig in
schatten der mauer war das areal ein
niemandsland lange passiert nichts 2003
entsteht auf dem brachland zunächst ein
techno club und später das kulturzentrum
also ich glaube den holzmarkt der konnte
nur hier entstehen nur in berlin und
auch nur an diesem ort hier konnte ganz
lange keine stadt wachsen das war eine
narbe
und daraus hat man natürlich die
situation vorgefunden das man
gestaltungsspielräume hatte dass
freiräume gab die noch nicht bebaut
waren und die noch nicht geplant waren
insgesamt 302 wachtürme standen auf dem
todesstreifen und waren teil eines
brutalen grenz systems heutzutage sind
nur noch wenige erhalten von diesem
wachturm wurde einst die grenze zwischen
dem ost berliner bezirk treptow und dem
westberliner bezirk kreuzberg
kontrolliert heute ist der turm ein ort
der kunst und steht unter denkmalschutz
susanne wachtum nach dem mauerfall aus
um so sieht es heute aus es ist
unglaublich diese vorstellen dass vor 60
jahren von thun mit diesen auf menschen
geschossen wurde
[Musik]
in dem zehn meter hohen bau befinden
sich inzwischen ateliers für
kunstschaffende auch ausstellungen und
events finden jährige mäßig statt der
geschichtsträchtige ort wird vom
künstler kollektiv the watch betreut
warum ist es so wichtig kunst hier in
einem wachstum aus zu stellen also den
turm zu aktivieren ist wichtig weil wir
jetzt 30 mehr als 30 jahren der fall
nämlich eine frage von social symbolik
ich arbeiten müssen was bedeutet das
eigentlich 2021 in einen ehemaligen turm
die ein ganz apparates gehört zu arbeit
und es ist wichtig da künstlerin
konzernen einzuladen die immer wieder
diese nacht in biel setzen und neu
definieren
und natürlich ist die east side gallery
immer einen besuch wert 13 kilometern
das längste noch erhaltene stück der
mauer in berlin heute auf der früheren
ostseite eine freiluftgalerie
die bilder wurden erst nach dem
mauerfall gemalt zu ddr zeiten war das
unmöglich am spreeufer sind viele cafés
und grünflächen entstanden die mauer
kann man sich hier auch von der
unbemannten rückseite anschauen
[Musik]
galerie schon oft gesehen aber noch nie
aus dieser perspektive
ich kann nur weil ihn nicht als geteilte
stadt vorstellen
sogar auf dem wasser gab es einen
grenzverlauf hier wo sich heute auf der
spree ein schwimmender pool befindet
patrouillierten 1 grenzsoldaten mit
booten auf dem fluss das badeschiff ist
städtisches kulturprojekt und
touristenmagnet
diana pineras trifft den architekten und
die kuratorin warum haben sie sich für
diesen ort entschieden
das hängt eben mit dem grenzverlauf
zusammen und der grenzverlauf war eben
natürlicherweise die spree das hat
natürlich auch viel mit der wasser
situation gemacht und wir wollten diesen
zugang wieder öffnen
[Musik]
reste der ehemaligen grenzanlage auf der
spree kann man heute noch von hier sehen
heute habe ich sehr viel gelernt und ich
bin ganz begeistert was nach dem
mauerfall alles neues in berlin
entstanden ist und jetzt dass sie schon
hier wen muss ich natürlich einen
schwindlig
[Musik]